yeah well denise people here on the west
side woke up to their very own winter
wonderland this morning
we are here at the vistas park near
summerlin west and although the snow has
melted
there are still some families out here
playing on the playground
and we are seeing some flurries coming
down again even at this hour
now take a look at this video this is
video from earlier today
from this same exact spot you can see
the snow really coming down
at the vistas park the fresh powder
covering the grass
the snow fell all across the west side
of the valley from mountains edge and
summerlin to centennial hills and sky
canyon
viewers sent us all these videos
capturing the snow as it fell
big flakes were also seen out in the
henderson and the anthem area
the flurries were relatively light but
those we spoke to were still
very excited you can build a snowman
or you can you can make a snowflake
and and i like to make snowflake because
even time i go i love it
and we might not be done just yet
there's a chance for another round of
snow later this evening and overnight
ted florendo will tell you more about
that in just a little bit and as a
reminder
because of the snow and the rain it can
cause some slick conditions on the road
so if you are
driving out there be sure to take it
slow and stay safe reporting live
tonight orco mana 8 news now